good afternoon everyone
sadly we are now now able to confirm
that yesterday we recovered Nicola Bully
from the river wire
Nicholas family have been informed and
are of course devastated
our thoughts are with them at this time
as well as with all her loved ones and
the wider community
we recognize the huge impact that
Nicholas disappearance has had on a
family and friends
but also on the people of Saint Michael
we would like to thank all of those who
have helped during what has been a
hugely complex and high emotional
investigation
today's development is not the outcome
any of us would have wanted
but we hope that at least it can begin
to provide some answers for Nicholas
loved ones
they remain foremost in our thoughts
the case is now being handled by his
Majesty's coroner
a family of us that we read a statement
on their behalf I'll now hand over to
detective Chief superintendent Pauline
Stables to do that
Nicholas family have asked that we
release the following statement on their
behalf as follows
our family liaison officers have had to
confirm our worst fears today
we will never be able to comprehend what
Nikki had gone through in her last
moments and that will never leave us
we will never forget Nikki how could we
she was the center of our world
she was the one who made our lives so
special
and nothing will cast a shadow over that
all girls will get the support they need
from the people who love them the most
and it saddens us to think that one day
we will have to explain to them that the
Press
and members of the public
accuse their dad of wrongdoing
misquoted and vilified friends and
family
this is absolutely appalling
they have to be held accountable this
cannot happen to another family
we tried last night to take in what we
have been told in the day
only to have
Sky News
and ITV making contact with us directly
when we expressly asked for privacy
they again have taken it upon themselves
to run stories
about us to sell papers and increase
their own profits
it is shameful they have acted in this
way
leave us alone now
do the press and other media channels
and so-called professionals not know
when to stop
these are our lives and our children's
lives
to those who genuinely helped and
supported us privately we thank you
the community support in St Michael's
friends neighbors and strangers
has been nothing short of comforting and
heartwarming
friends you know who you are thank you
our hearts truly break for others who
have missing loved ones keep that hope
alive
finally
Nikki
you are no longer a missing person you
have been found we can let you rest now
we love you
always have and always will
we will take it from here
thank you thank you everyone thank you